une audition très attendue celle des
acteurs de la banane il se présente en
déclinant tous les bienfaits de leur
production aujourd'hui mais au bout de
20 minutes
le président de la commission on rentre
dans le dur en étant factuel
l'utilisation de la chlordécone dans la
banane durant plus de 20 ans a pollué
les sols de martinique et de guadeloupe
et à la question est ce que vous êtes
disposés à financer la dépollution des
sols
la réponse était éteinte je peux pas
vous répondre aujourd'hui mais c'est
déjà une bonne chose
répondre aujourd'hui parce que tu
apprends donc j'en ai pas donc la
compétence si demain adopté les
solutions qui se fait jour
donc on est on est prêt donc à
l'accompagner à mettre donc en place le
dispositif qui permettra effectivement
cette dépollution que tous nous ne
pouvons que souhaiter face à la série de
questions des députés
le directeur général de l'ugp ban
renvoie ses interlocuteurs vers l'état
qui est pour lui en première ligne dans
ce scandale sanitaire
les responsabilités sont multiples et de
nombreux éléments inquiétante entre 73
et 80e puisque ces temps on a déversé de
la chlordécone dans ce pays guadeloupe
et martinique est sans aucune
autorisation sauf sur nos pauvres qui a
aidé renouvellement tacite ou pas et
nous sommes en train de vérifier cela
tout au long de cette journée marathon
beaucoup de questions ont été posées à
différentes personnes
leurs réponses vont enrichir le rapport
de la commission et il s'agira pour la
commission et pour celles que je suis
est bien de formuler des propositions
parce que les populations des
territoires de guadeloupe et martinique
attendent des réponses claires sur un
sujet ô combien complexe sensible et
douloureux qu'est la pollution
auckland et quand l'état qui a accordé
les autorisations d'utilisation des
pesticides contenant la molécule
chlordécone sera entendu le mois
prochain
le rapport lui doit être présenté d'ici
le 4 décembre